My name is Jim Cloos. One of my primary tasks
is drafting the European Council conclusions,
so at the level of the heads of state and government,
and that is why I am also sitting in
the room when the meetings go on so that I
can quickly react when leaders want changes
in the text.
It happens quite frequently that they change
or they add things and we have to be very
quick in sort of capturing what they want
to express in those conclusions which is then
translated into all the official languages
of the European Union.
'BRUSSELS, DECEMBER 2013 - EUROPEAN COUNCIL'
It's a very complex business of course because
we are talking about 28 heads of state and
government. So it's not an anodyne meeting,
it's an important meeting, it's a meeting
where decisions are taken. So there is a very
elaborate way of preparing this, under the
authority of Mr Van Rompuy of course. The
European Council is a club, you feel it in
the room. There is a sense of responsibility.
The leaders - the heads of state and government
- want agreements, they want things to move
forward. They don't want to come out and say
we disagreed on everything. So it is difficult
work, there is a lot of tension, there is
a lot of fighting, that is democracy after
all. I mean democracy is about ideas, very
often controversial ideas, then you sit around
the table and you try to find a solution.
And that's what it's all about.
FROM CRISIS, OPPORTUNITY
Europe's Story
It has been a massive crisis, and probably
the biggest one, but not the first one and
I would even say it's not the last one, because
that's the way things go. Very often the Union
actually emerges stronger from crises. This
has been a pattern in history. Now this has
been a very serious crisis, and it has been
extremely painful, but if you step back and
look at what has been done, I think it's a
major step forward. And I'm utterly convinced
that the Union will emerge stronger.
Today we are still in crisis,
an economic one, a social one, etc.
But we're no longer in a situation
where it's like we were standing before the abyss,
as if Europe could explode from one day to the next.
And I think that these political motives, this profound
determination to continue this adventure together,
has its roots in the long history
of our continent
with its wars and attempts at peace.
So, it's part of history that starts, perhaps,
with Napoleon or Bismarck, but also,
of course, with 1914 and 1939-45.
'YPRES MENIN GATE MEMORIAL'
To soldiers killed in World War I
In the battlefields around Ypres, 600,000
young men were killed. 600,000. So this was
100 years ago, and we thought after the First
World War that we could organise a lasting
peace. Unfortunately, we only started the
process of reconciliation in Europe after
a Second World War with even more victims.
So that's the very beginning of the European
Union, that is really the European construction:
built on the graves of millions of people.
And it was right there, on the ruins
and the debris of that Europe,
that a certain number of countries got together
to say: 'Right, never again.
We no longer want to kill ourselves, between
the Germans and French, and all the others,
and we want to start something new'. So,
the moment of European foundation
is really based on that idea of peace,
which was very strong at the time
for statesmen, the elites, but also
for the people. It's still felt today,
at least by the leaders, that the Europe
we have now and that we want to build,
that its reason for being, at its
deepest level, is still peace;
good relations between countries.
'BERLIN, 1989 - FALL OF THE WALL'
The Fall of the Berlin Wall was one of
the most beautiful moments of European history
in the 20th Century. It was a time when
Europe became conscious once again,
in a way, of its unity.
The 10 new member states came to us, to the
European Union, as a result of the end of
the Cold War. So they lived during decades
still in the atmosphere, in the climate of
the post-war period.
We are now negotiating also with Serbia, with
Montenegro, most likely with other countries.
So the European Union is still a dynamic process,
a process that is going step by step covering
the whole territory of the European continent.
It is still an attractive project, and people
tend to forget this.
Enlargement has been, I think, a massive achievement.
Let me say this personally, when I arrived
in Brussels in 1985 we were 10 member states;
we are now 28. That's a revolution. And actually
if you ask the countries outside of the European
Union, a lot of them want to get in.
Look at the debate in Ukraine for instance.
It allows you to develop law, a legal system,
a system of an internal market which functions,
and all of that. If you think that now we
have countries which 20 years ago belonged
to the Soviet Union, and they are now members.
One of them, Lithuania, has just had the Presidency
for 6 months. I think it's a miracle.
This revolution which we saw, which turned
even bloody, made very clear that Ukraine
is different than Belorussia or Russia, that
Ukrainian people are more pro-European. But
still the country is not unanimous on this.
I think that we cannot exclude Russia from
any developments in Europe, and that Russia
is a neighbour, and anyway Russia is an economic
partner, anyway Russia is a main energy supplier,
and Russia is a huge country, partly in Europe.
Still the time is very turbulent.
But the people understood that they will not
allow politicians to mismanage the country,
they want to be directly involved in the decisions
of their country's future. And this is also
an example for us Europeans; if governments
with corruption, with mismanagements are overshooting
their legal responsibilities, people in such
countries can take their own decisions, and
try to influence the future themselves.
We need to give no illusions, neither for the
new government, neither for Ukrainian people
that the road will be difficult. We can only
help, but everything that they started to
do, they need to finish themselves.
When we saw the waving of the European flag,
it was a very strong signal that European
values are still attractive, because what
were they defending? The values of democracy,
the rule of law and human rights
against a regime that uses manipulation, lies, blackmail
and at the end even violence.
Real change cannot be imposed quickly. A dictator
can impose something, but it is not going to last.
This is the beauty of the European
Union. Every member state, whatever the present
circumstances - there might be some economic
or political or other difficulties - takes
over the Presidency for six months. Of course
it doesn't rule the Union for six months;
it chairs one of the institutions of the European
Union, a very important institution: which
is the Council. It renders a service for six
months. So now for 6 months I am almost a
Greek civil servant in a way because I work
directly for and with the Greek ministers
and the Greek senior civil servants. So a
presidency is not somewhere in the void, and
has to get up in the morning and say: 'What
I am going to do with Europe tomorrow?' It
is part of a system.
I think we should not be stupidly, naively
optimistic, but I still believe that Europe
is a continent which has a lot to offer. The
Union does a lot of things. Free movement,
circulation. You don't have to stop at the
borders. Our students can travel, can live
in other countries. All of this is now taken
for granted. And I think we should encourage
young people to grab their chances and to do it.
The Union will be what the people of
Europe will make out of it. And there are
ways of influencing, there is a way of making
your views known nowadays. So you should do
that rather than constantly lamenting and
saying that things are going badly. I think
Europe has a huge potential.
- Produced by the Council of the European Union -